hello this is these guys for simply
learn and today's topic is Google
Analytics during this session you're
going to learn how to create a new
Google Analytics account if you do not
already have one
and the way you do this is you go to
Google I mean you pull this up here you
go to google.com slash analytics and you
click you click on analytics here it's
loading here and then what you want to
do is you want to click on the admin tab
and you want to create a new account as
you can see I just walked through here
you want to put your account name here
your website name here and you also want
to be very careful when you are putting
in your domain name or your URL your
universal real or resource locator here
you want to make sure you put in the
proper prefix whether it's a HTTP or
HTTPS you can get the separation by
looking in the URL bar at the top as you
can see here this is the URL here you
also want to make sure you select the
category and your timezone everything
else and then you want to get a tracking
ID now the the tracking ID let me go
back to the one menus your tracking ID
is where you grab it from here on
tracking info I'm not going to go into
my tracking ID for this one here but
going back to the five we we've went
over how to create a new Google
Analytics account so that and then
setting up a property and then following
the instructions to set up the web
tracking code once you've created your
Google Analytics account you want to
make sure that you properly copy the the
code snippet and you want to paste that
into the header of your website now if
you're using either a wordpress site or
a Shopify platform or a few other
website content management systems
there's already a place designated place
that you can actually paste this code
and the content management system will
properly give the syntax that you need
for your website there are a few ways to
collect page tracking data you can add
the Google Analytics tag the universal
analytics for your website container
using the Google tag manager which you
can also access from the login that I
showed you before the google.com flash
analytics you can see the tag manager
login right here this is loading here
and then you can just set up an account
and follow the directions that you see
here Google tag manager is great because
it automates the propagation of tags
throughout your site and it just makes
it easier to track to make changes role
changes out to your site and also to
implement the code tracking directly
into your site now you can also as I
mentioned before implement the tracking
code directly into the HTML of every
page of your website now if you have a
website that is HTML purely HTML driven
with no content management system you're
going to have to insert the tracking
code directly yourself however if you're
using WordPress or Shopify there's
typically places within the theme where
you can
that information now the whole purpose
of Google Analytics is to get data to
help you make better decisions and to
improve the user experience of your
website so that your customers will want
to come and buy again and again and new
people who come to your site will want
to buy and start patronizing your
website now one way to attract the
effectiveness of your user experience
and your products is through the use of
a goal template now if you take a look
here let me grab this one here you can
go to your admin panel again and you'll
see here I'm going to highlight this so
you can see who spot like the sirs of a
goal here if you go to admin on the new
account that you created you can go to
goals and then it's under the view as
you can see here and when you go to
goals they actually have some templates
here so I actually have one goal here to
create a new goal all you want to do is
click the red button that says new goal
and pick from one of the choices that
you have here you can either track
orders that are placed account new
accounts that people created your
website you can measure engagement if
you know people click on your social
media buttons on your website you can
track how people you know Add to Cart
just to give you an example I can do do
an example of the social connect so you
select that one and then you want to
call this and we'll call this
Facebook call that Facebook quick and I
want to graph I put in the wrong okay
here we go okay so I have to write you
want to make sure you have the right URL
there so I grab the right URL and so
want to say that this is the value -
okay begins list actually begins with
piece and I want to verify the skull
let me pick that off
okay so we'll try this all right well
let me go back to this one is set up
properly I can just walk through this
one so this one is for placing an order
and the goal description is um thank you
and then the details I put in the
destination equals to check out slash
thank you and when you verify this goal
you'll see that there was a one point
five six for version rate based on the
data from the past seven days so you
know that this is a good goal and you
can continue to track this information
now going back there's we talked about
two different goal categories we have
revenue acquisition inquiry engagement a
destination goal like the one that was
successfully set up basically tracks how
many people what percentage of the
people on your site goes to that page
successfully land on that page of their
destination and so I know from the
architecture of the website that that
thank you page let me go back to it here
that this Thank You page right here is
the destination for those who
successfully complete a purchase so that
is on the goal that I was tracking there
now as that goal is triggered one of
user does something specific like
download a PDF or start a video pages
the amount of pages that people visit
there's another goal that you can track
and also how long they stayed on the
website now this is really cool because
you can really capture even more data
from
visitors to your websites using Google
Analytics and this is through what we
call the Google Analytics URL builder
now the Google Analytics URL builder
allows you to track the source whether
it's search engine social media or any
other site that a newsletter e email
that you're using so as you can see here
the source is the referral and then you
have the medium and then the terms that
you want to track so say you want to
track how popular a certain new product
is or one product versus another you can
actually track that information using
the Google Analytics URL builder so um
key metrics to monitor are really
important so I want to show those next
and this is um one project that I'm
working on right now and as you can see
the sessions have went from 350 in a
month to eight thousand one hundred and
eighty-three and there are out of those
eight thousand one hundred and eighty
three eight thousand one hundred and
forty are unique visitors and out of
those eight thousand 140 unique visitors
they have viewed a total of nine
thousand four hundred and fifty-five
pages on the website now if you look at
the pages per session the pages have
went from two to one page per session
and the average duration is very low and
then we have a bounce rate that
increase so this this data tells you as
an analyst as a SEO person that there's
traffic coming to your site that is not
100% the target demographic because the
amount of time that they're staying on
the site now if you I can show you the
difference here the the bounce rate here
on another project I'm working on is a
lot lower its forty six point eight
percent you have a lot less sessions a
smaller number of users a high number of
pageviews so is about almost five pages
per session that people are viewing so
you can see depending on the different
vertical you can have different issues
to resolve and Google Analytics is
really great for highlighting the things
that need to be addressed and tweaked on
within the SEO strategy of your website
now things that are really really cool
to see is this is like a decision or a
traffic tree you can access this in your
Google Analytics and let me go to your
tree Maps here this is it and
[Music]
we go back to oh use our slope this is
the one I wanted to look at so you can
see the user flow this is very similar
let me change the so you can see from
here you can see the different this is
an example of where people are coming
from how they travel through site this
particular map that I picked up and have
the country with starting pages and it
just drill down and drill down this is
um similar on the screen slash here so
Google Analytics is really helpful
because you can slice and dice the data
in in many many different ways now the
next part that we're going to talk about
is qualitative data this is the data
that is more I like to say touchy-feely
or data that tells a story so the type
of tools that you can use we're going to
talk about a few of those but
qualitative data is best obtained from
visitors to your site through surveys
and polls and there's you know three
three questions that you want to answer
with your your data
remember people have short attention
span so you don't want to ask too many
questions
so you want to stick to things like why
are you here were you able to complete
complete your task if not why not
why did you you know come to the site
questions like that are really cool and
then from this data you can also
calculate the net promoter score which
basically
is the question of referral it helps to
quantify the probability that a visitor
to your site would indeed prefer your
company or your products services to
someone else as you can see here now one
of the tools that's really great another
low cost tool is called koala rule now
this enables events triggered surveys on
your site and this is an example here of
what that survey looks like to the user
as a pop-up on your website so in order
to set up a koala roof survey what you
want to do is you want to go to the
website and then you want to name your
survey you want to pick your question
how likely is it that you would
recommend this blog this website or this
product service to a friend or colleague
you can word it as appropriate for your
your needs your business needs and then
you want to make sure it's required
acquired for 100% well
percent of your visitors and you can
also target how they came to your site
in order to see the pop-up so one thing
you want to make sure that you have you
don't want to display the survey before
30 seconds because 30 seconds is
typically if a person is going to be on
your site for 30 seconds or more it's
not a bounce and you want to make sure
you don't have any data that you're
collecting from people who aren't your
ideal client so the next thing is you
want to don't want to be too too
persistent about it I know some of us as
marketers we want things to be shown
until a visitor provides a response
however you know I would don't want to
be too pushy so so here's an example of
the responses given on that question
were you able to find the information
you were looking for
in summary koala rule is a simple way to
run you know really short surveys on
your site to either collect customers
service related data or to ascertain
what your website's Net Promoter Score
is being the probability that people
will prefer your website to other
colleagues or friends now the next tool
I want to talk about is a tool web
engaged you can go to web engage comm
and you can as you can see here is the
home page here and you can also use this
tool to to gather qualitative data from
your website visitors so when you're
setting up a web engaged survey what you
want to do is fill out you know the name
of the survey the email that you want
the feedback to go to and when you're
when you're setting up a web engage
survey you want to really let me go back
to that you want to you know gather the
information this this is the web engage
forum where your user your visitors can
put in their name their email what kind
of feedback they have if they're happy
sad etc and any message that they have
for you this is the the web engage tool
now the next tool that you can also use
is the Google consumer surveys now this
tool can be accessed through the Google
Form tool I believe I have yeah I set up
one here when you're setting up a Google
survey you want you can go to google
form and select surveys and it will take
you to this screen that you see here and
this this tool is pretty cool
it costs a little bit of money as you
know some of the tools do but it's not
you know astronomical it's not you know
twenty-five dollars answer or anything
like that so it's very affordable Google
consumer surveys also allows you to
create satisfaction surveys for your
site and as you can see here want to
highlight this so you can see it's not
like this you can't get these the survey
inserted onto your site to gather more
qualitative data from your website
visitors so this is a closer view of
that survey at Google survey what if
anything do you find frustrating or
unappealing about this website you can
ask your visitors that and yeah Google
Android survey is a powerful tool for
you to gather the qualitative data that
you need in order to get the feedback
you need from your website visitors now
you can also set up a free website
satisfaction survey as well by just
copying the default survey there copying
that code and putting it that code
snippet on your site so remember you can
get a free survey using Google consumer
surveys by using the default website
satisfaction survey just want to make
sure you get that point and so the code
snippet that goes on your site is
provided by Google for you to use on
your site and you can also use this tool
for mobile mobile devices as well which
is really cool
now inclusion you know surveys are
important because they explain why
people either love your product or
believe it needs improvement and the
best survey asks only three questions
you want to limit to to very few
questions and there are many loads no
cost tools for surveys you have Google
survey they have a default one if you
want to do a customized one that does
cost a little bit and then there's also
the low cost web engage and quality that
we covered right now this next session
section is about experimentation and
testing the benefits of testing is very
very important because your your your
website or your mobile application is
that
testing environment and in this testing
environment the the customer can give
you information about what works and
what does not work now testing also
allows you to to be really creative you
can test colors you can test spots you
can test placement images many things to
to increase your conversion rate and
then once you find what works you can
scale very quickly you can scale out
those improvements and really bump up
your your your cash flow and your bottom
line so back in the day in the past
circa you know 1999-2000 you know
website design was really based on cool
ideas and what we like to call suppo the
highest paid person's opinion and there
really were not a lot of tools available
to help you create the best customer
experience or ways to measure those
recommendations and you know the thing
about technology is a lot of the things
that worked many many years ago even a
year ago online become obsolete and
don't work so you know the half-life of
good ideas are very short online and so
that's why it's very very important to
be very strategic and methodology and
and deliberate about how you roll out
changes and track them and this is
what's so great about testing hypothesis
testing and statistics is is where you
make an assumption about a certain
attribute of your website maybe you make
a certain
about your price point or your shop now
button placement or your the colors that
you use so I mean there's many different
things that you can make a hypothesis
about and then you want to test it so
basically you know to really simplify
this is like if this independent
variable then this this dependent value
variable will cost this change so if I
put you you know calabrese font then my
cells will increase so just to give you
a hypothetical and that example and so
here you have what a be testing you have
those the a the B options so may maybe
I'm testing you know impact font versus
Calibri and a website a is a certain
font is the colibri and
[Music]
okay and so as I was saying before say
version a is Calibri version B is impact
so you can see here in this different
scenario Calibri if that was the version
a that would have has the biggest impact
the most positive conversion aspect so a
B testing just helps to remove the
speculation the highest-paid person in
the room to basically put the hands into
the consumer and to find out directly
from them what they want to see what
urges them to purchase what urges them
to subscribe
what urges them to download what urges
them to give them your email whatever
the case may be so the great things
about a/b testing is that it uses
existing resources it's very quick to
get started and it really sets the stage
for even more complex testing the the
cons is you have less control over
external factors and it's very limited
to very small and simple changes like I
said before like an image or a font or a
certain color or a certain layout or
even phraseology that you use certain
worse convert better than others
now multivariate testing is way to test
multiple variations of multiple factors
all at the same time and in it a B
testing you need to test each of those
changes one after the other and you also
need a certain amount of traffic before
the test is significant testing and
individual factors may give one result
with taking collectively the best
combination need not be one of the
individual that
because as you can see here from the
examples you have a different tie color
you have a different box color and
different headlines so this gives you
kind of a pictorial representation of
the different scenarios that I spoke
about earlier
now multivariate testing allows you to
see the impact of different combinations
of changes all at once so you can change
any aspect of a webpage and see how many
different permutations people gravitate
to which ones convert and so here you go
is the number of variations on such a
versus the number of variations on
factor B and the number of variations on
factor n so so if you have four factors
or four variations each then you have
you have 256 permutations now the pros
of using this this technique the
multivariate testing that you can test
very a large number of things all at
once and it's you know good way to
overcome IT limitations and it's faster
to to bring more changes quickly however
this time of testing requires really
high traffic it requires thousands upon
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of hits visitors to your site
in order to really have data that has
relevance and value and with something
like another thing is that there's a
tendency to optimize for smaller changes
and ignoring the bigger ones and the
lastly this isn't the best for every
niche now
the next section section we're going to
discuss is competitive intelligence this
is a something that I really get a kick
out of as a digital marketer is looking
at what other people are doing so
competitive intelligence is often about
benchmarking it's about putting your
organization's performance in context
another way people call competitive
intelligence is kind of when you do a
SWOT analysis and you focus on the teeth
the threat however you know competitive
intelligence is is limited and it can
empower you or paralyze you so when
you're benchmarking your competitors you
can definitely use insight on their
performance to your advantage so you can
look at what I really like to look at is
their search terms the kind of traffic
they have to precise averaged anytime
that people are using on their site the
bounce rate how many unique visitors you
can really grab a lot of this this
information and even though it's it's
simply to ask questions like what like
what's a good conversion rate what's an
acceptable bounce rate it really depends
on your website vertical and a lot of
other factors so this this kind of
information is very important to to use
wisely
now one way of benchmarking I love to
use and this is amazing and it always
helps to add momentum to a marketing
campaign is to establish your baseline
and track your improvement over time and
you can use metrics such as traffic
visitors and McGrath and its average
time on site and all of these are
available through simple online tools
about your competitors and so to check
those tools reliabilities you can
compare your own data was how you know
tool reports of the same so you can
there's a lot of ways that you can get
data and know whether or not it really
it works so one really good thing is to
to assess your your competition using
their technological footprint one tool
that you can use is called built with
you can use built with com to perform a
competitive analysis and then you can
also use compete that's another tool
that you can use to gather data on your
competition and compete is actually
really good because it gives you Alexa
ranking gives you you know monthly
visitors to the site it gives you a
bounce rate and a bunch of other great
data points so
as you can see there and highlight it in
the yellow you can put in the name of
your competitors website and then you
can pull their their their data right
there as you can see site summary for
getting images calm now you can also
look at the incoming visitors and we
also talked about the statistics earlier
on Google Analytics where we talked
about the number of pageviews the number
of visits and there's also compete has
its own ranking system as well called
compete rank and as you can see on the
right you can also see the phrases by
which people are searching for getting
images calm and when you put in your
competitors website in to compete calm
you can also pull this data on your
competitors as well so there we have the
keywords and the incoming traffic from
the various sources so you can see here
that Getty Images has the majority of
its traffic coming from Google followed
by Yahoo followed by being followed by
Facebook YouTube and we care comm and
AOL calm which is you know for mix of
search engines and social media channels
as well as Twitter is there at the
bottom you also have outgoing traffic
from the site as well then you have your
your your your demographics by age by
income and by gender
this is all on compete
calm now the next step is to prepare
your performance to your competitors
performance and you can you can do that
by confusing the parasites tool within
compete calm as you can see highlighted
here and this is really cool because you
can actually compare the traffic the
unique visitors so you can see the green
I like this so you can see it see the
green here this is getti getting images
if you follow the red highlight here
that's getting images and then the
orange you can see is another competitor
is istockphoto.com and so you can just
imagine if you go to compete calm you
put in your website and then your top
four or five competitors you can also
see their traffic compared to yours and
that's very informative as well
the power of competitive intelligence
that it helps you to understand exactly
where you stand within the marketplace
so as you can see again this is a
getting images calm in comparison to
Shutterstock sx c hu dreams time is all
box photo fights that as a graphic
designer or an e SEO person you're
probably very familiar with these sites
now if you're in real estate this is
another vertical you can see the
difference between century 21 Coldwell
Banker realtor.com Remax and Zillow and
as you can see over time amihai like
this you can see that Zillow is
garnering more traffic than the century
21 realtor.com
Remax and Colo banker so this is a nice
example of even another vertical so you
can see exactly how compete.com helps
with competitive intelligence gathering
so you can see a realtor and Zillow are
highlighted in yellow so the data again
but you can look at much actually let me
go back here one thing I want you to
ticket take a look at this is over time
you have three months six months one
year in two years so you do have that
flexibility that part of the tool like
when you're comparing you're comparing
different sites to yours you want to
make sure that you do take advantage of
the time frame there as well
comparing team metrics with your
competitors can bring immense insight it
can definitely
remove any complacency that you may have
had or it can show you that you're
definitely on the right track you're
ahead of the pack in the middle of the
pack are eating everyone's does it'll
really give you perspective into your
your your place so another analysis to
run is your competition traffic sources
and patterns
some companies may get most of their
website from Facebook some may get most
of it from a certain website maybe they
have a powerful blog strategy so when
you compare their traffic sources to
yours you can actually uncover some t
digital strategies that's working for
them that you're replicate that will
definitely work for you so here is
traffic referrals for getty images calm
and you can see here that we have four
portals miscellaneous social media it's
all kind of charted out here for Getty
Images
yeah so this is really cool because it
gives you the numbers and also a
graphical or pictorial representation of
the traffic and the sources so as you
can see here Shutterstock has two times
the traffic of getting images and
they're getting the lion's share of
their traffic from web portals and
search which lets me know that there's
some terms that getting images can go
after that it currently is not that it
can gain more traffic from that are
working and then you can also see here
that is direct traffic for Shutterstock
and getting images is about the same how
however Shutterstock really relies on
organic visibility and that's something
that getting to considered for more
resources into so this that is really
informative on what tweaks you can do to
your strategy in order to to make more
of an impact online so so when you look
at the getting images miscellaneous
traffic sources you can actually you can
drill down even more and if you look
here you can see that getting images has
no visibility on all free download
console this may be a website to
consider getting on investigating how
Shutterstock is using all free downloads
if you're using you know selling it
marketing or some kind of paid ads or
if it's a directory or however it works
it may prove get the images to get on
that fight so there's a lot of really
great insight that you can gain by
drilling down into your competitions
traffic sources and so again just like
with the online consumer surveys there
are many cheap or free online tools you
can use to conduct your competitive
analysis I also um in addition to
compete similar web is also a great
source of competitor data some other
tools that I've used in the past include
some rush spyfu full rank
just just to name a few to competitive
analysis is great because it helps to
put your performance in context it helps
you to understand what your competitors
doing are doing differently and what you
can do to catch up with them in certain
aspects and it also helps to uncover
great opportunities for your business to
grow and evolve the next part of our
presentation today is about tracking
parameters this is really interesting
because it allows you to track where
your traffic is coming from and how your
traffic is interacting with your site
we're going to just go more into that so
what is a UTM tracking parameter it
helps you to identify and come and click
from a campaign and it's not a tag and
it's it's um which is usually with it as
tas within the URL to to your to your
site and it gives you the reason why you
use it is because it gives you precise
control over how to categorize your
marketing click
you can use tracking parameters to track
the amount of clicks that you're getting
from your email versus your social media
sources uh the search engine the type of
search engine and the phrase within that
search engine so as you can see here
these are all your your traffic sources
so here we have website search engine
Bing the word is coffee and too when you
go to Folgers coffee if you click on
that link these are the the UTM
parameters so tells you Bing
cost per click and the terms coffee and
this is a campaign that you're using to
track and call soldiers non-branded
that's the URL that a user is accessing
your ad from so breaking this down
Google Analytics uses the source the
medium the term and the name of the
campaign but it ignores the article ID
part of the URL now there is one caveat
with AdWords is some automatic tagging
that goes on but as we showed you before
you don't have to use every single
parameter we'll talk about this more in
depth as you can see here so this is
Auto Tech from
AdWords campaign okay so I'm going back
to how Google and let lytx categorizes
your traffic sources so direct means
that a person directly type your URL
into the browser now referral means that
it wasn't through a search engine and
there's no you can parameter or any add
AdWords parameters either so this is
referrals can be a backlink to blog
posts now a search engine is another
category as well and search engines does
have parameters as Paignton and
campaigns have parameters as well okay
so when you set up a campaign so you can
track these parameters there's a total
of five that you can use you don't have
to use all five but you can use as many
as three four or five now as you can see
the source is you want to identify the
advertiser the size of publication etc
that's sending traffic to your property
so that could be an example of Google
Yahoo Bing AOL medium it could either be
if you're tracking affiliate marketing
or if you're tracking cost per click
campaign a banner ad an email newsletter
another part is on the campaign name
next whatever you decide to to name the
campaign and then the term if you're
using PPC on a search
like Google or being and I hear the
conversion rate I know the conversion
rate on being is very very high for
their paid ad you can use UTM term to
track which keywords are yielding more
sales through tracking your goal and
this can actually help you to tweak your
your dollars so that you can have even
an even more effective PPC campaign and
then the UTM content depending on if
you're using a video or using different
links within the your ad you can yes
or if you have two different links
within your ad you can use the UTM
content to specify which one which link
is driving more conversions and this is
really cool information so there is the
best practices for you using UTM
parameters to make the activity the
activity data usable is that you want to
use just enough if you don't need the
detail don't include it and skipping one
or two parameters is normal and it's
very rare to use all five and then you
also want to make sure that your
spelling is consistent we especially
upper and lowercase letters and the
order doesn't matter and leave other
parameters in the URL so here are some
examples of your tracking parameters
so this is a display ad on Volcom and
this is a banner ad and this is for the
fall colors this this would be a great
ad for a clothing line this is what
their the URL sources would look like so
that's the source vogue the medium is a
banner ad and the campaign is all colors
now now you can see the source is the
same folks the the banner is a banner ad
but there's also fall styles you can see
the articles so here's another example
where the source is Facebook and it's a
banner ad and the campaign you're
calling it falls out so I mean there's a
lot of different options that you can
use within Google Analytics to track one
thing you also want to make sure of when
you're setting up this type of thing on
in your Google Analytics make sure that
all the the cases are similar to URLs
and make sure you test that so here's
another example so if this is an
e-newsletter you can see this is the
different scenarios you can track it per
each month now when you're tracking
social media if it's Facebook and they
can't
the brand page you can see the power of
this if use the meetup comm if you're
using Facebook Pinterest Twitter now
here our offline vanity URL I'm going to
always also use that as well you can use
this to track Flyers if you have a
certain URL you want to use an applier
or commercial this is also helpful to
use this
now this is pretty powerful stuff so as
you can see here when you when you
designate the source the the medium the
campaign name you can also shorten those
URLs and use those those offline vanity
URLs and commercials Flyers means
different sources in order to drive
traffic and also at the same time track
how people have came to your your
website so when you are diagnosing
issues with your data one good thing to
do is to really look at everything side
by side as you can see here you can use
Google's Ural URL builder and also
access Google's basic documentation for
support as you're troubleshooting now
we're going to talk about Universal
analytics why Universal analytics
well reversal analytics is is really
really important and it's a great way to
gather data we talked about this earlier
we're using Google Analytics you can
track a lot of different important
factors like unique visitors page of you
total pageviews new versus existing and
a whole host of other statistics and
there is so much to your analytics a lot
you can can measure so with the
proliferation of devices you have
tablets you have cell phones smart
phones you have laptops and desktops and
you know all sorts of devices it's very
important to track how people are
accessing your site so that you can pour
your resources into those things that
are very important so traditional web ad
or Linux fractures your data but with a
Google Analytics you can actually track
things in a more seamless way so
Universal analytics allows you to look
at the visits the people the customers
and just you know look at the different
ways that people access your site so I
know for like for instance if you are a
emergency key company you'll more than
likely find that most people are
accessing your website through cell
phones because most people who get
locked out of their cars or get locked
up in a house and need a person to to
get them into their car or home or
usually just have usually just have
access to their cell phone so you know
it's really important to use analytics
Universal analytics so you can see where
you need to pour in your resources so
okay I'm going to get some so technical
lingo in here so a user ID override so
we live in a world with with with wide
variety of people and devices and things
and it's really cool to gather this this
data and and be able to make sense of it
to be able to analyze it and to use it
in such a way where it makes sense and
you can draw conclusions and make a lot
of business decisions so
Guga analyst gives you a measurement
protocol for both um online art or
digital traffic foot traffic it could
track commercials it can track traffic
by email trusted by flyers a whole host
of different things when you set it up
correctly so this is this is really
really really cool so this is a an
example of the on how to use the user ID
feature that allows you to associate
engagement data from various different
devices here and you can access this
under the property if you go to admin
and properties you can go under user
management tracking and both to user ID
click there and get to this screen that
you see here this is just magnified you
have to agree to the user ID policy
and then you just want to put that new
code within your Google Analytics this
is your Google Analytics code here you
want to just insert that underneath your
Google Analytics number but before the
the Google Analytics script tag ending
so this is your your property code
number that you want that user ID code
to be inserted under yeah you want to
replace that with your existing account
ID now you can get a user guide to the
Google Analytics user ID by going to
this website WWWE /g au fer i D and so
now you can see the data once you've
been in incorporated a tracking of user
ID you can see how many people who come
to your website are anonymous or have
identified themselves and this is very
helpful as you're doing remarketing or
or other things to with your with
thought you can do remarketing on foot
on Facebook you do remarketing on Google
and remarketing is really powerful tool
allows you to take those unique visitors
and you follow them around okay
so as you can see here
you can see the difference between the
users that have enabled their ideas and
those who have not so the blue is those
users who have enabled their IDs the
green are anonymous one and so you can
really see the device overlap for those
who have identified identified
themselves and those who have not and
also you can track the revenue as well
using these tools you can see this Venn
diagram here
well I think this is really important to
note that when you use user argue you
can really track people by their device
there's so many different devices people
are using and it just helps you because
you know websites render differently and
so you can definitely use this to your
advantage okay so with this user ID
override that we we talked about you can
really widen the amount of analysis that
you use on your data so instead of just
being a number you can actually create a
a Betar of your your customer and create
even better experience and so when you
gather that data no no longer who is
that person you have more information
you know their you know what the gender
is their age what their likes are and
etc now customer loyalty data is great
too
retention data is great for remarketing
I've touched on that a little bit that
and campaign data for on and offline
initiatives is really good content data
to know which content by what authors on
your website is really having an impact
and also product categories and all that
data falls into the dimensioning
widening category so when you export
this information from Google Analytics
you can export it as a CSV file as you
can see here format it with
in a spreadsheet application like Excel
or OpenOffice and you can really start
to tweak your initiatives and your
website experiences to appeal to the
target demographic so you're moving
beyond just um just a code to you know
an age and a gender and education level
with your customers are becoming
individuals that you can really cater to
in a bigger and more powerful way when
you use that data and so when you create
those avatars you can also track authors
- you can track education level which
authors appeal to which education
demographic whether it's high school
PhDs master's etc and this is this is
just really really really cool so I mean
you can see how your your products
appeal to single individuals versus
those who are are in families and this
information really helps you to tweet
your website experience in a bigger way
and to pour more resources into catering
to those who identify more with your
products and services in this scenario
you can see here that single booking
travelers have a higher likelihood of
spending money on this travel what fight
so
yep so when you compare it the dollar
amount versus how many goal completions
you'll actually see family travelers
have per transaction send more money so
the data does not lie it does not lie
and as you can see here when you look at
it just on the surface we drill down and
really analyze it really can open up
some opportunities and inform your
strategy in a more effective way so when
you are are importing data you want to
go to my accounts and go to my property
and then go to a data import and there's
more directions on this at WWBT ue / ga
da Pai n again that's WWBT lima flash GA
da ta i n and you can also visit Google
Analytics help for more examples on data
imports on how to do that so we talked
about how user ID override can help you
to to basically look at your data from a
more personable standpoint where it's
more than just a number you can see the
demographics the gender the device are
using their likes or dislikes and this
actually helps you to write into
dimensions by which you're analyzing
your data and and Google Analytics also
gives you a measurement protocol by
which you can track in store
traffic offline conversions physical
sensors there's there's a lot of
different ways as you get more
sophisticated with your technology that
you can track traffic and you know what
offline interactions happen you can send
that event back to Google Analytics
through the measurement protocol this is
really really powerful and then it can
be combined with the visitors original
activity when you use the user I mean
the user I need overriding and other
things and so this is this is really
powerful to paint a very complete
picture of your consumers consumer base
so as you can see here from Google
Analytics you can track the event the
category type of action what you want to
label that as and the bit value and
using this you can group all offline
data with the value client offline
conversions as the value for all hits
from offline traffic so it's really
powerful for you to see and you can also
change their status within the system
depending on what it within the Google
Analytics depending on what actions they
take online versus offline
and so the event value it can be set to
the value that you establish for in
offline activity that you're tracking
through the use of a vanity URL so
here's an example you have you have a
per visit goal value the form sign up
offline opportunity you can see the
different sources and the mediums here
on the left and then you can see how
those individuals interacted with on and
offline um
marketing choices or activities
so you can see that the first goal is
the form signup and if there was an
offline opportunity if the form finance
was for an event you can track all of
this information all within Google
Analytics so here's the second example
you can integrate your customer
relationship management system when
you're offline sales as well and with
online sales Google Analytics is called
from the consumers browsers but with
offline sales the consumer isn't present
so a different approach is used and this
is the best method is to to make a
server-to-server call to Google
Analytics and this this method requires
developers to to execute and as you can
see here it's coding intensive
but you definitely have this this power
within Google Analytics to integrate
your customer relationship management
system with your offline activity and it
being tracked within Google Analytics
through your ERP speaking to your Google
you can read more about this at WWE q /g
AM total call that WWV q /g am PR OT o
co l ok so more Universal analytics
benefit is that it can handle session
timeout campaign timeouts
you can add customer dimensions Google
Analytics is really powerful there's a
lot of of ways that you can use Google
Analytics to widen the dimensions and
the depth and breadth of your data you
can go to WWE qi UGA custom dimensions
for more information about this and now
on the next session is enhanced
e-commerce for Google Analytics and you
can use enhanced e-commerce capabilities
to create funnel reports on your
checkout you can see where people drop
off whether it's at the the shipping
payment or the reviewing portion of the
shopping experience so you can can
definitely gather some really great
insights so you can see how many people
are going to completion and where people
are having problems so you can create a
checkout funnel reports with Google
Analytics you can also do a shopping
behavior analysis as well with Google
Analytics and this basically helps you
to see who what visitor is coming to
your site or tie kickers and which ones
aren't this is really helpful especially
when you're looking at the sources and
keywords that that your your traffic is
using to get to your site so you can
focus more on two words where people
have a higher likelihood of making
purchases and you can use assemble
your analysis to uncover that
information about the traffic coming to
your site now you can see in this
scenario there's about eight million
sessions coming to the website about two
million of those are looking at products
at about half a million of those or
adding a product to the part and about
half a million are checking out and then
about eleven well
one hundred and eleven thousand eight
hundred and fifty are completing their
transaction so this is this is this is
very very interesting information and is
very informative especially when you're
forming decisions and making a
determination about where your digital
marketing strategy ought to go tell talk
about the foreigners it's really
interesting to see the drop-off here and
you can see that this five point eight
million shoppers or with no shopping
activity no cart addition abandon the
cart you can see track all of those and
the shopping behavior analysis
so the other thing that's really good
about the shopping behavior analysis you
can look at it by device so here you
have the shopping behavior analysis by
desktop tablet and mobile device and in
this scenario you can see that the
number of people making purchases is
largest on the desktop device
you know tablet users start checkout
twice as often and complete purchases
fifty-seven percent more often than
overall users now when you look at pure
numbers it looks like desktop is a
larger population but if you look at the
number of transactions for mobile for
tablet users as a percentage of the
total tablet users you can see that they
do purchased 7% more often than overall
users as you can see here let me
highlight this so you can see here in
here
so if you look at it as a percent right
here tablet users purchase at a higher
rate and the data let's we know to
leverage remarketing more for our tablet
devices mobile users start the checkout
process more often than desktop but
complete purchase forty percent less
than overall users very interesting so
in this scenario the tablet purchasers
are definitely purchasing more and you
can see you can see the difference
between mobile users tablet users and
desktop users the see the different
percentages here
now if you look at the percent of
transactions a mobile it's pointing to
percent versus 0.82% versus tablets
which is 2 point 17 percent versus
desktop which is 1 point 3 6 percent and
so this lets me know that you definitely
need to fix the checkout experience
because mobile and desktop experiences
are close to the same in their
conversion rate and so that makes Sydney
having to be fixed so when you're doing
your shopping um behavior analysis you
can really drill down into the null
shopping activity the milk carton dishin
the cart abandonment and the sessions
with product views with a jacquard with
the checkout and with our completed
purchase so when you're looking at that
chakra behavior analysis you can also
look at it by device by country
and as you can see here is that you have
India has a lot of sessions with product
use and so forth you can really see it
okay coding is very important so this is
about capturing events in the shopping
funnel so there's a lot of different
ways you can tend capture it so here you
see the product information here so
diagonal strap gym bag and what
categories accessories the brand google
variant system and you want to track the
action want to captured a page view here
so this is how you code in Google
Analytics how to code capturing events
in the shopping funnel
and so you have your hierarchical
categories and then you could do clicks
detail add remove check out payment
refund on the various uh actions to
change this here to clicks Admirals etc
etc and then the event also a segment as
well as you can see sessions with
product news at cart you can create an
e-commerce section here ecommerce
segment and then you can also analyze
the market Beck's gift so this is a
really cool so there's a lot of
different ways you can slice and dice
Google Analytics data so you can do you
can track the campaigns for different
products to compare how they're
performing how they're generating
revenue you can look at that compared to
other products and really drill down you
could create product lists you can track
by category Google Analytics is really
really powerful and you can see how the
performance of your site's merchandising
is going as well and see how much people
want to view your your product list
even the
you might also like suggestions as well
and you can track the click-through
rates bunch of stuff so Google Analytics
is really really powerful and you can
see here from this data the
click-through rate for the product list
is the highest for that you might also
like category on this website and you
can also track the revenue generated
from each product category and this can
help to inform your your inventory
strategy as well you can use Google
Analytics to track all of this
information
and you can figure out what she which
products our product lines are most
popular which ones are added most to the
cart and which ones are purchased the
most by using Google Analytics to track
product category and product lists now
internal marketing our social promotions
internal coupons things of that nature
that you use to to your to the traffic
that you already have access to that you
own and this something that you can also
track using Google Analytics as well as
you can see here your internal promotion
names are here and you can track how how
many views your promotion gets how many
clicks through and the click-through
rate and how much how many transactions
and having how much revenue generated by
those total transactions in the various
categories of different internal
promotions so as you can see here the
different promotion name and click
through rate on those promotions and the
number of transactions per quick you can
see here that the drinkware campaign is
generating some good revenue there you
can compare the different scenarios so
internal promotions I know that and know
my clients often run internal promotions
and this is a great way to to try
back track those things there and you
can just you know go to the internal
promotions part and pick what medium
that campaign is happening happening in
and just configure your Google Analytics
you can also track coupons as well if
you're using coupons online or offline
coupons you can also track affiliates
too if you're if you're running ads on
other websites as well you can track
your your affiliates and also affiliate
marketing if you have affiliates for
your site you can also do have a
behavior analysis on your marketing
efforts so this is basically taking
those who have abandoned your marketing
is good for those who have abandoned
their shopping cart initially and
tracking how they come back so this is
how you would use dynamic attribute
linking and to do remarketing
you